[music]
the white caviar from the albino stöhr is
just very, very rare far very
few animals there are albino checkered
dehydrated is mixed with gold it is
the most expensive food in the world
at 100,000 euros a kilo
[music] my
name is walter green if today just as
big  joy or at us over 30
years ago the passion
started with me at the age of 34
probably started fishing my
football is called fish farm green a
nice place for animals and to live there
where they have time to
grow up to grow up
it  is a cycle and in the end
we get a special product and
the case is that takara albino caries made
the product better known to us
but he knows it stöhr is of
course much much rarer than
everyone else but with the trout
and char need caviar  maybe
two or three years to be able to harvest caviar bothers me
as long as it does
n't happen overnight if you do
it says it takes 14 to 16 years
to harvest caviar
our white cover can be eaten by all
the people who
buy
it from us, including top hotels
or private individuals again one
says he wants it on ice there others
all over  taste the back of the hand the
third vodka every person
decides for you we enjoy the product
how very soft in the mouth patrick
simple wonderful taste
experience but really try it taste taste it is the crucial thing
[music]